- [Kelly] We have time for
one more story before we go.
This is what I'm liking.
Disney World is known as
the happiest place on earth,
but as many parents will tell you,
preparation is key people.
If you're not mentally,
physically, and financially ready
the Magic Kingdom will eat you alive
and will be a day from hell.
A Pennsylvania dad understands this.
He's posted his Disney workouts online.
Here you go.
(upbeat music)
That is so true.
I'm like, I ain't carrying
you around this park.
My kids are always asking me.
So I say hi to Matt and his wife Rachel.
- [Rachel] Hi
(cheering)
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Hi Kelly.
- [Kelly] Matt...
- Thank you so much for having...
- Oh my god
- I'm such a huge fan.
- I love y'all
and I love that you're
putting these videos out
'cause this is totally what my kids
you're nice, apparently,
Matt, you'll actually do it.
But I'm like, nah, God gave
you two legs you can walk.
This video looks like it was born
out of hard earned experience.
So is that true, Matt?
Are you usually carrying them
like that all over the park?
- It sure is, Kelly.
When you have a wife that loves Disney
and you have four small girls
ranging from nine to two
I'd say I've had a lot
of practice with this.
You have someone who likes
to plan down to the minute.
So I've had plenty of times
where I've walked 20,000 plus steps a day.
- Oh my God.
- You know, tried to
navigate the double stroller
through Main Street and had two kids
on my shoulders in 90 degree heat.
So you know it, it's definitely
an intense experience.
- I sometimes it's like
while being the happiest place
on earth for your children
it's like the opposite
for the parents sometimes.
So Rachel, this was so popular
that you made several other
training videos, right?
- Yes. So when you have
as many kids as we have
ranging with the ages that they are,
we've experienced just about everything
that there is possibly
to experience in Disney.
So we created two more
videos with our family
on experiences and those
have also gone viral.
And then we recently created one
with my father-in-law
about grandpas at Disney
and that's gone viral too.
So it's just so relatable because I feel
like all parents kind of deal with this,
but we we do it to give our
kids the magical experience
that we wanna give them.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
It's the hanging on the pole
while trying to, oh my God.
It's all so true and relatable.
I love y'all.
Thank you so much Matt and Rachel.
I'm liking your post right now.
Right.
- [Matt] Thank you.
- [Rachel] Thank you, Kelly.
- That's not all. Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to help you prepare
for your next Disney vacation,
at least financially.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
- Wow!
- Wow, thank you so much.
- [Kelly] I love your family.
- Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] You're hilarious.
Thank you for joining us and thank you
to all our guests this hour.
Riley Keough, Suki
Waterhouse, Camila Morrone,
Taylor Jenkins Reid,
Sadaya, Dora, and Sunny War.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.